so for a closer look at what's happening
in ukraine let's bring in julia
cochitova she's a photographer
documenting the russian invasion in kiev
thank you so much for joining us um i've
been looking at your instagram feed and
the
each photo tells such a vast story
before i get to your pictures though i
want to talk about what things are like
where you are right now what is keeve
like as i understand it russian troops
are slowly sort of circling the outside
of the city
hi everyone i'm reporting from kiev
that's my city actually i'm based here
uh like the news getting worse and worse
we have the official statement made by
the advisor of the minister of the
interior but in denison saying that like
in couple of days the main battle of
this war gonna happen the main battle
means the battle for kiev so
uh
also i've got the news that the state
armed forces of ukraine just smashed
russian troops between
sumi and kharkiv they were coming to to
get closer to the capital as well
uh like the whole mood is pretty
depressing i should say because like my
city is absolutely empty
there are still shops and
drug stores which are still operating
but mostly people who are staying here
they are involved in defending groups or
they volunteering
but
like the mostly part of the
local citizen they just gone because
it's pretty dangerous and now you're
like you're showing the pictures which
i've took in the nearest district where
i'm staying
it's on lebanon it was a civilian
building which was just uh
attacked a couple of days ago
and nobody predict that uh because there
is no military base nearby uh the only
uh nearest
client was the airport
that's what the idea why this
uh civilian building was attacked
but still
that's the latest news from kiev what i
could share with you you know as a
photographer right part of what you do
is you capture sort of a sliver of a
moment in time preserve it forever but
it's a moment that tells a bigger story
um i'm wondering from because all of
your pictures are
really amazing but from you what photos
really stand out do you think tell
people around the world what's actually
happening
um
i'm not sure that you've got it in our
in the folder or not
when i was filming there
abandoned like the the damaged building
um
on lobos
i've seen the piano
which was like totally destroyed so just
electric piano lying down uh on the ash
and
different parts of
the building and i realized that
actually
that's something what
could describe
war in general because that the moment
when music stops that the moment when
everything is stopped and
you just like
can't continue your normal life yeah all
your best settings they're just
and you just should stay
and try to
find yourself in this new reality yeah
julia you know it's not just your photos
i think when i was looking at your whole
sort of instagram grid it's like 12
sets
of war and then literally right before
that
it's normal life
and i think it really sort of lets you
know how rapidly things changed
and the other thing that struck me was
that you're taking photos of regular
people these are not members of the
military these are not politicians
what have you learned about your fellow
citizens your fellow ukrainians your
neighbors in kiev from documenting them
under this these conditions
i should say that now they are on the
age and like as a photographer as a
filmmaker i always was interested in the
people in transition
but i'd never expect that this
transition gonna happen in my city
and
when they are on this age
all feelings they are so naked all
feelings all fears all hope
they're so obvious so that's pretty easy
to get with the camera but still it's
pretty fragile to get closer and closer
to the usually people in need or people
who are suffering and that's something
what i'm always trying to bet inside
myself because there is this classical
journalism dilemma either you should
film or support
uh what's gonna do and like in my
experience i've been covering war since
2014 i've been covering the annexation
and my gun revolution and clashes
which were happening in kiev but i've
never been covering
that kind of cruel russian aggression
happening in my town and i've never been
covering people who should
leave their home
who should be afraid of being killed
while they are just staying at home in
the center of europe that something what
like i'm
mostly faced with and i'm mostly trying
to
manage insight julia right before we let
you go uh the other thing that i noticed
is that you switched from writing in
ukrainian i think to writing in english
so clearly you want the world to
understand what your the stories that
you're trying to tell so i ask you
before i let you go what is the message
that you want the rest of the world to
hear
i want to say that actually
we now and
the most cruel and aggressive war
happening in the center of europe
started by russia in 2014
and that's all what leading by that
silence which was made by the whole
world
we got this point when my city is
bombing because
previous eight years this hybrid and
proxy war was just uh
kindly accepted by a lot of countries
like i'm sorry to say but that we were
saying that we're
fighting against russians for the last
eight years now they're bombing the
whole country but they've got to this
point because of the silence which was
so
the main message which i've got it just
like that silence always kills and
that's something the whole world should
learn
um i'm terribly sorry that you've got
this lesson because of my country
involved in the war but
maybe we as the humanity should learn it
and never ever repeat that let's pray
that that's the case uh julia please
stay safe
do not put yourself at risk
unnecessarily no photo was worth it we
want to be able to continue talking to
you after this but thank you very much
for joining us this morning
thanks for inviting me
all right if you want to check out
julia's photos head on over to her
instagram uh it's at s-e-a-m-e-e-r